This is Donna.
How's that?
And this is Donna's office.
Hey! I'm Donna Sarkar and right now I'm in Barbados.
Donna works as a software engineer for Microsoft.
Before the pandemic, she rarely worked from home.
When this pandemic set in, I honestly had culture shock.
I've never worked a job where I have zero human interaction in my 20 years of tech.
So, it all started June of 2020.
We've been now in lockdown since March.
We're not going outside,
We're not meeting anyone.
I see this random article that said Barbados is offering a one-year remote work visa...
...to foreigners all over the world.
And I thought, that's kind of interesting.
Three months later, Donna and her husband said farewell to their home in Seattle...
...and up sticks to Barbados.
Last night, we sat out in the boardwalk...
...and had rum punches and tacos and overlooked the ocean,...
...and it was magical.
It was a throwback to a time like almost a year ago when you could do that.
Working from paradise was made possible by a special visa...
...which allowed Donna and her husband to continue doing their jobs in Barbados...
...while still paying income tax in America.
When I dial into meetings, people are like,
"Oh, look at you and your beautiful sunny skies outside."
And I'm like,...
..."Yeah, sorry not sorry at all"...
...given that in Seattle, it's gloom and doom and dark at four o'clock and raining.